now I like to introduce our featured
presenters today dr. lu Halima and dr.
Niccole Yamada dr. halleck is a
professor in the division of neonatal
and developmental medicine in the
department of pediatrics at Stanford
medicine and as the director of neonatal
resuscitation at Packard Children's
Hospital dr. Helmick is the founding
director of the center for advanced
pediatric and perinatal education and
the world's first center dedicated to
fetal neonatal pediatric and obstetrics
simulation-based training and research
he is a former member of the board of
directors of the International pediatric
simulation Society the inaugural Board
of Directors of the Society for
simulation in healthcare and the
inaugural editorial board of simulation
and healthcare
his career and simulation based training
and research began in 1995 and over the
past two decades he's refined a method
of debriefing based on his collaboration
with colleagues in aerospace aviation
and the military this objective
professional approach debriefing has
been adopted as a standard for the
neonatal resuscitation program of the
American Academy of Pediatrics it's
25,000 instructors and 3.3 million
trainees dr. Yamata is a clinical
assistant professor in the division of
neonatal and developmental medicine in
the department of pediatrics at Stanford
medicine and is an attending
neonatologist in the intensive care unit
at Packard Children's Hospital dr.
Yamata is the associate director of the
center for advanced pediatric and
perinatal education she's an expert in
debriefing teams of healthcare
professionals from all areas of clinical
care and of all levels of experience she
has worked with teams from both academic
and private hospitals all over the US as
well as teams from around the world and
she's been invited to deliver simulation
instructor programs in Moscow and Hong
Kong and with that let's turn it over to
dr. Hellenic and dr. Yamata Thank You
Jackie for those kind of introductions
I'd like to emphasize the fact that both
dr. Yamata and I are practicing the
innate ologist so we look at debriefing
from the vantage point of health care
professionals who are leading teams of
people in the care of critically ill
patients do you want to acknowledge that
our training and debriefing strategies
as you mentioned
been heavily influenced by colleagues
and other industries who are outside of
healthcare and we're in those industries
the expectations for both human
performance are high as well as the risk
to human life is high and especially
like to say thanks to people that we've
known over the years both at NASA and
the FAA for whom from whom we've learned
so much I'd also like to point out that
while our discussion today is really
focused on healthcare debriefing the
strategies that we're going to highlight
over the course of the next 40 minutes
or so can be applied when debriefing any
type of situation and that's going to be
especially important for our audience
today because we wrecked we saw that
approximately half of you are actually
working in industries outside of
healthcare ok so let's get started the
learning objectives as many of you are
aware from when you signed up for the
webinar are these listed here and
they're really specifically related to
our selection of wanting to discuss the
really foundational strategies that we
think are instrumental to running an
effective debriefing now outline for our
webinar is first we'll just start with
what is debriefing a brief definition
there so that we're all on the same page
about what we're talking about today and
then we'll first cover some guiding
principles about how we generally think
about debriefings
and our approach to debriefings in any
situation and then finally we'll roll
into a discussion of four specific key
strategies with video examples of things
that we specifically implement through
all of our d3 things I think it's worth
mentioning that these are only just four
strategies out of a total of 20 and we
cover all 20 in our online debriefing
program which you'll hear about later at
the end of this webinar but these aren't
all of the solutions to running an
effective debriefing we just wanted to
cover what we think is really
instrumental and foundational during
this discussion so the first question
that I think is worth answering is what
is a debriefing and so for those of you
who may not be familiar with what
debriefings are we really wanted to make
sure that we're all on the same page
about what we're discussing here today
so debriefing at a
very basic level is an interactive
discussion of a prior series of events
and can be facilitated in a number of
different ways into different levels of
involvement from the debriefer and
oftentimes that depends on the
experience level of those people being
debriefed
so people who may have a lot of
experience with debriefings may be able
to even start to conduct their own self
debriefings as a team whereas other
people who may be less familiar with the
role and the function of a debriefing
may need a little bit more facilitation
from a train to debriefer or someone
with experience with debriefing the next
question is what is a good debriefing so
now we know what a debriefing is how do
you make it how do you make a good
debriefing a good debriefing is one that
is constructive concise and identifies
both strengths and weaknesses and
oftentimes especially those of us coming
from an environment where we're training
other people or we're educators we often
focus on what people need to learn what
they might need to improve on
and one of the things that we really
want to emphasize is that the good
debriefing is an opportunity to talk
about both strengths and weaknesses and
helping those that are being debriefed
understand what facilitated their
ability to perform really well if they
had a really strong performance and how
to replicate that performance again in
the future and also then taking the
opportunity to address weaknesses and
not only identifying them but coming up
with strategies to help those people who
are being debriefed learn how to avoid
those same challenges or those same
weaknesses again in the future so let
Lou talk about some of the guiding
principles that we have for debriefing
so we'll go ahead and review those now
first guiding principle is that
instructor should always maintain a
professional businesslike matter-of-fact
tone whether training performance was
exemplary or highly flawed our overall
goal is to enable the people being
debrief to eventually be able to debrief
themselves we want them to be able to do
this without the need for a trained
debriefer certainly in healthcare it's
not always going to be possible
if we'd be briefing real-life situations
to have a trained debrief or present and
so we want to allow them opportunity to
practice this and we want to draw as
much information from them and self
critique as we can during that
debriefing that ability to assess their
own performance becomes extremely
important especially when we were
working in the real environment second
guiding principle the role of the
instructor in debriefing is to
facilitate rather than dominate
discussion among trainees when I need a
debriefing my expectation at those being
debrief will actually be most the
talking and I can be relatively quiet
now that doesn't mean that if a team
does not recognize the performance gap
that I'm not going to eventually
intervene but I only intervene only
after I've tried as much as I possibly
can to draw that information draw that
self critique out from them the briefing
should be focused on the actions of the
individual trainees how those actions
contributed to the performance of the
team how team performance influenced
patient outcome that is absolutely
critical we have to get to what happened
to the patient and how the actions are
the team actually led to that in the end
what we want is we want the people being
debriefed to develop strategies for
replicating those actions that resulting
good care of the patient in other words
successful human assisted performance
but also to avoid actions that are
ineffective or harmful so we again we
really want them to be able to reflect
and develop these strategies themselves
and there should always be in any
healthcare debriefing a discussion of
what happened to the patient this is a
real key point technical performance to
briefings which is what doctor Yamada an
idea these are different than critical
incident stress debriefings these two
types of debriefing set of different
objectives and no attempt should ever be
made to try to conduct them
simultaneously and a technical
performance debriefing is not therapy
technical performance debriefings and
critical incident stress DV the
briefings are often confused in health
care that's been our experience
and the way to distinguish these two is
that a technical performance debriefing
is focused ultimately on what affected
the care of the patient and how the
patient did where is a critical incident
stress debriefing is focused on the
emotional health of those who are caring
for the patient now both of those are
very important both of them have their
place but again they have very distinct
and very different objectives and so
don't confuse those two when you are
debriefing okay so we'll roll into our
discussion of these four key strategies
that we really wanted to dig into today
and again these are just four of 20 but
what we're what we'll do for the next
portion of the webinar is actually
introduce each strategy followed by a
video clip from a debriefing showing
that strategy being implemented by a
debriefer and then we'll have a little
discussion afterwards about really why
we feel that those strategies are
important and what we're hoping to
achieve with with each each of those
just a comment on the clips that you'll
see these were taken from debriefings
that were recorded to illustrate
specific points so while the actors in
these debriefings were asked to portray
specific roles for both the scenarios in
which they performed and then the
subsequent debriefings they're all
practicing healthcare professionals but
the debriefing itself was not scripted
and really implemented these strategies
as they would be in any debriefing the
first strategy again is one that I think
applies to all debriefings and it's
really just how to prepare learners or
people being debrief to participate in
that debriefing and we want to show how
you can clearly communicate expectations
at the very beginning of a debriefing so
in this clip it's the first 40 seconds
of the first debriefing with this group
of people being debriefed and the
debriefer who's starting to lead that
discussion anyone else's performance
outside of this space the conversation
certainly is open to everyone so even if
you weren't playing a role in that
particular phase of the scenario please
feel free to chime in with any
observations
I thought you may have the open to
learning especially be open to learning
from our mistakes be able to accept any
critique both gratefully and gracefully
and then finally we have a lot of
potential things that we could discuss a
lot of things that we could potentially
discuss but we don't have time to do go
through all those today so we'll try to
hit the major points okay so dr. llama
what are your goals as the debriefer
when you make these types of statements
at the beginning of everything well I
think as you could see in here in that
particular video segment I have some
very specific goals things I want to
communicate at the beginning of their be
debriefing when I'm first meeting this
group first of all I want to ensure that
absolute confidentiality is going to be
maintained during any sort of scenario
whether it's a simulated scenario real
scenario you may see weaknesses become
manifest and so those are things that we
want to keep confidential within the
group that's being debriefed we want to
ensure that there's psychological safety
meeting that actually people feel safe
and comfortable talking about their
mistakes within the group that's
assembled I would like to see active
participation from all members of the
group although I don't mandate it I know
that some people actually are quiet by
nature and as long as it appears that
they are mentally engaged and they're
learning I don't push people to talk but
I certainly would like to see that I
really want people to be open to
learning from mistakes if we are running
simulated scenarios in general those are
about making mistakes and learning from
those so that's a real key expectation
that we set up front and what I talked
about at the very end that everyone will
accept critique and remember critique is
not criticism but that everyone will
accept critique both gratefully and
gracefully and I have to thank my
colleague and friend at Johnson Space
Center Mike sterling for that because
that is sort of the mantra that they
live by when they debrief astronaut
crews and flight controllers and then
finally especially if you are working in
the real environment where you you don't
have a lot of time to debrief
after a real event is occurred with
patient care because the teams have to
go back and take care of other patients
in that unit so for us we're debriefing
issues within the ICU or with in labor
and delivery then we definitely need to
make sure that people understand we only
have a few minutes for this debriefing
therefore we're going to cover the most
of what we think are the most important
topics and then we're going to move on
and is that something that you cover at
the beginning of every debriefing well
it depends if it's the first time I'm
meeting a group and certainly I'll talk
about those things I want to make sure
that my expectations are clear to them
and they know that this is going to be
an environment in which they can freely
talk about the mistakes and learn from
them on the other hand if we're running
a training program or maybe we're
running four or five scenarios over the
course the morning or the day then I
won't repeat those every time as long as
I'm sure that people understood them
heard them the first time and so then
moving into actually initiating the
debriefing itself one of the things that
we always talk about and when we talk
about how to really run an effective
debriefing is starting with this
question what happened in ten words or
less and so this next clip will show
this first question being asked by the
deep briefer and then the initial
responses given by the people being
debriefed to start off what happened in
that scenario and ten words or less term
neonate umbilical cord rupture needed
blood good I would say
term neonate hypoxic hypovolemic full
resuscitation anyone else the other
additional input
many debriefers in healthcare have been
taught to or even prefer to start their
debriefings with a question along the
lines of how did that go or how did that
feel and the question here asked was
what happened to Integra nor less why do
you start debriefings that way oh well
that particular question you know how
did that go for those of us who use
video it often times it's hard to know
exactly how that went what happened
before you've watched the video and have
a chance to actually assess performance
so we try to avoid if we're going to be
using video whether it's a real-life
scenario that were playing video back
for or it's a simulated snow we try
avoid getting into the debriefing too
much with an assessment just based
solely on memory we'd rather watch the
video and critique it in real time so we
avoid that question and we also avoid
the question is in terms of how do you
feel about that I know that's very
commonly used and people are free to
choose however they would like to start
their debriefing but I've not heard that
question asked in other high-risk
industries that do debriefing I think
that it can set the debriefing up to be
confused with the critical incident
stress debriefing which again as we
talked about earlier critical incident
stress debriefing and technical
performance debrief into two very
different things
and what we're really talking about here
today are technical performance
debriefings and so I try to avoid those
kinds of questions because they can be
rather subjective and at times rather
vague so by saying what happened in ten
words or less we try to accomplish a
couple of very important things first of
all we try really hard to set a
professional businesslike matter-of-fact
tone for the debriefing we want people
to know that you know you know saving
lives is our business that tone is
extremely important for the debriefing
and we don't want to waste anybody's
time with superfluous conversation
especially if we have very limited time
to cover important topics in patient
care that's the first thing that it does
the second thing that it does is it does
encourage people to be concise and
precise in their use of language and as
we discussed a
I've mentioned several times now that
especially when debriefing in the real
environment where time pressure is quite
intense and we have after we've taken
care of one patient and we briefed that
we have other patients that are waiting
for our care so we don't have the luxury
of lots and lots of time for to debrief
a real situation now we may have that
luxury affordably thing simulated
situations in a training program but
even there we don't want to waste time
our my experience over the last two-plus
decades and using simulation healthcare
is that what teams really want is they
want to get in as many scenarios as they
possibly can so if we are being
redundant in our briefing if at least
they're perceiving that perhaps we're
not covering in a new material during
the debriefing or discussing things
aren't terribly important then they
start to get ENC and they would much
prefer to be in another scenario and see
what more they can learn rather than
continuing to talk about things that
perhaps aren't as relevant as they
should be
then what happened in ten words or less
is a very specific question to sometimes
another strategy that I've seen
debriefers use is asking the questions
what went well and what didn't go well
in that scenario and starting out a
debriefing that way can you comment on
how that strategy compares to using what
happened in temperature less again a lot
of these things are personal preference
sometimes in the real environment and
when time pressure is intense I'll see
people say well what where all they
typically start with what went well then
they get to or what did it go so well
the only issue about that is that it for
example let's say we determined that you
and I are working on a patient and
something did not go well let me say
okay the intubation that patient did not
go well if we don't then drill down if
we don't give to the underlying causes
of why that intubation did not go well
and it can be something like deficit and
content knowledge we didn't know what
size in particular to use we didn't know
how to properly handle the laryngoscope
it could be a problem with
decision-making we didn't make the right
decision we decided to intubate too soon
today too late it could be that our
actual technical skill our hand-eye
coordination of the way they we handle
the laryngoscope and in a trachea tube
wasn't appropriate and didn't allow us
to be successful or it could involve a
host of behavioral skills around
communication maybe we didn't
effectively ask for the right size
equipment maybe the ambient noise level
in the room is too high and we weren't
able to hear one another all of those
kinds of things and all of those skill
sets can actually influence why
something did not go well or why it went
very well and goes into being the
critically important aspects of what
happened that you want to cover during
the debriefing so if you just stay at
the very superficial level or you know
tell me three things that went well and
three things that didn't go well again
if you have a great limb at a time you
have only a few minutes care and and
briefing that gets people thinking about
those particular aspects but it doesn't
drill down to the underlying root causes
and that's something that we really need
to be able to get to at some point
during a debriefing so your hope with
what happened in ten words or less is
just the beginning and then really the
rest of the debriefing is to discuss a
lot of those other issues more in
specific terms that's correct yes okay
so moving on to the next strategy this
is titled avoiding qualitative
statements and it really describes our
goal of trying to draw a performance
assessment from the learners or from the
people being debriefed and then just to
give the audience some background on the
clip that's being used here this is
taken from a debriefing of the care of a
premature infant who is in respiratory
failure and in need of CPR and at this
point the group is discussing the team's
decision of whether to intubate the
patient prior to the initiation of start
of chest compressions and we will see
that the trainees or the people being
debriefed address a question directly to
the debriefer and what I want to point
your attention to is how the debriefer
responds and the discussion that follows
from the trainees what do you think is
it difficult to intubate while someone's
doing compression you ever done that
let's let's see if we have any consensus
among the group so the choices are to
not do compressions and intubated focus
on the intubation
guess it was mentioned that sometimes it
can be difficulty in debate while the
chest is moving especially in a very
small patient another choice is to start
compressions
and hold off on intubation perhaps to
bag mask the other choice is to do both
simultaneously do we have any consensus
among this team about what should be
done right now with the heart rate of 26
4 minutes roughly a little over four
minutes of age I think if the innovator
is comfortable you should start with
chest compressions and intubation at the
same time okay but if it's starting to
interfere then you should hold off on
the chest compressions because the
intubation is most important it only
takes a brief moment and it does take a
while for you to build up enough blood
flow to have appropriate and cerebral
perfusion pressure okay okay so backup
team comes into the room and the backup
physician is immediately given an order
to intubate so watch what happens from
this point so in this clip we
demonstrated this concept of avoiding
qualitative statements what does that
mean concretely it means to avoid the
use of adjectives and adverbs and the
way if you are leading the debriefing
and the way you're speaking with the
team and avoiding providing any sort of
qualitative assessment of their
performance you know we've talked about
several times already in the course of
our discussion here today that it's
really important for members of these
teams to be able to look at their
performance reflect on their performance
and come up with their own assessment
it's not going to be possible to have a
trained debrief or available to run
through the hospital 24 hours a day to
be present for every debriefing that
should be taking place and so we need
our teams to be able to do this I think
it's a professionalism issue I think
it's the issue of quite honestly
delivering optimal patient care so they
have to be able to reflect on their own
performance and decide whether that
performance was optimal or not if it
wasn't optimal okay what are the
weaknesses let's identify those
weaknesses and let's begin to discuss
they can show those weaknesses don't
become manifest in the future similarly
if it was if the team performed at a
very high level yeah
if their performance was deemed to be
optimal under the circumstances they
really need to understand what it was
what it was that enabled them to perform
at such a high level because it's it's
one thing to do a really good job at
something it's another thing to
understand how to replicate that good
job in the future yeah and so it's not
just about weaknesses it's not just
about good performance it's actually
about understanding the underlying
causes or the abilities that are the
circumstances that actually allowed to
perform along that performance dr.
mm-hmm but in this situation one of the
people being debriefed actually asked
you a question directly and you're an
experienced neonatologist with expertise
and unit or some citation and you've
probably had an opinion in this case of
whether or not the team did the correct
thing or the best thing for this patient
but instead you've responded with let's
see if we have any consensus from the
group why did you avoid answering that
question well I could have easily
answered that question and that team was
turning to me as the person that
answered the question tell them how they
did I don't see that as the role of the
debriefer again unless there is a
problem that that they aren't unable to
recognize the gap in performance where
you might need to step in and help them
recognize that you really want to draw
that answer out from them you want them
to assess their own performance as best
they possibly can
we typically debrief experienced health
care professionals that the team that
was seen in that video is it obviously a
team of experienced health care
professionals more than likely there's
at least one if not more people in the
room who know they answered that
question already at least they have
their own answer formulated and what can
happen is if I tell them immediately
what I think should have been done I
potentially can shut down discussion
they're going to say oh the debriefer or
dr. colonic just said this is what
should
dunno I was thinking maybe something
different should be done but if that's
what he says then that's what we should
go with and I don't want to make the
supposition that since I wasn't in the
Sun that I know exactly what it is they
were seeing what it is they were hearing
and go ahead and tell them what should
have been done because they may have
been alternative strategy that's just as
effective or perhaps even more effective
than what I might be talking about and
so I never want to shut down that kind
of discussion I want to give a time to
to come up to the surface because
oftentimes the people that are being
debriefed AB they come up with some very
unique and very valuable solutions to
these kinds of problems and I'd rather
hear from them first again that doesn't
mean that if at the end of a discussion
and after multiple attempts to try to
draw what I feel would be the best
answer out from him if they fail to
recognize especially a witness then we
do need to intervene we do need to call
attention to that and tell them the
right thing to do
we don't want them to leave that space
thinking that you know knowing that or
you know that they did something that
potentially could harm the patient you
don't want them leaving that space
thinking that that was the right thing
to do because that will lead to great
patient harm so you can't let that
happen but in general especially with
experienced health care professionals
which is someone who can draw the answer
from it's much more powerful but comes
from them rather than continue to them
yeah so we're talking a lot about
drawing assessment of performance from
the people being debriefed but the other
thing that this strategy was related to
is avoiding qualitative statements can
you give us an example of what that
really means sure is that this is when I
use all the time whenever I talk about
this if I have two teams with me and the
team one is coming out from acerra for
debriefing and I look at them and I say
at some point during that debriefing as
I'm conversing with them oh you guys did
a great job and then team two comes out
and they come up for their debriefing
and somewhere in that conversation I say
oh you guys did a good job what ends up
happening is even though both teams
performed at an adequate level the team
that heard the word great now is
thinking that their performance was much
much better than the team that heard
that we're good and so those are two
perfectly acceptable
they both indicate you know good
performance adequate performance yeah I
set up a dynamic here where that I
probably didn't want to set up there's
there's enough difficulty sometimes in
degree things especially with different
groups of people that they're reading a
lot into it anyway so my preference is
to not add to that not make it more
difficult for them to discern I don't
want them to just try to discern for me
what their performance is like but I'd
rather have it come from them and bubble
up from them because again they're going
to remember it much better and I think
be able to translate whatever it is we
talk about into their practice if it
comes from them right I've been sort of
in the grade school teacher type
teachers student type of role where I'm
the source of all knowledge they don't
know much of anything every time that
they have a question they ask me I
answer again with health care
professionals who are adults who are
intelligent people experience people
most the time we know that she's already
and I can imagine how that also helps
too and I've seen how that helps to
avoid creating defensive nough sandy
briefings too because you're really
asking for their own assessment of their
performance and they're not looking to
the debriefer for some validation or
some feedback the next strategy also
talks more about defensive 'no sand
really how to deconstruct offensiveness
and try to minimize defensiveness and
that's limiting the use of second person
pronouns so in this clip this is a
debriefing separate from the the one
that we just washed this is the
resuscitation of a full-term infant who
is in cardiac arrest and the team in
this scenario struggled to provide
timely care and so by this point in the
debriefing it's already been established
that several steps of the resuscitation
were delayed relative to the standard of
care and so because of that multiple
members of the team are unhappy with
their performance so let's watch this
clip to see how the debriefing debriefer
handles this challenging situation so in
terms of the ergonomics at the bedside
the crowding at the bedside is anything
that can be done about that anything
that could have been done about that
well the patient could have been bagged
from this side that I'm on now
so that would have freed up space okay
and what could have led to that not
happening in this scenario I think that
just not being aware that there wasn't
enough room for her to really get in
there and see what led to that lack of
awareness
I guess you may not say anything okay
and what prevent what could prevent an
individual in a situation like this from
speaking up about they don't have enough
room they're so focused on that task
okay I think it's hard to do it's hard
for me to speak up sometimes hard
because I don't want to let the team
down or I don't want people to think
that I can't do something when I can do
it but the circumstances aren't exactly
right and sometimes that's just really
hard for me to verbalize but the most
important person is the patient and
they're the ones that really needed the
line so it's true I feel like we have to
find a way to get over that and take it
over
you know and to be okay with switching
roles and saying I can't get this done
right now you know anything else that
any other member of this team could have
done to determine that intravascular
access was not yet secured I think the
team leaders could have checked in
earlier team leader could have inquired
about that okay
anybody else on the team could have
enquired about that right I think I
definitely could have because when
you're doing ventilations and
compressions it's hard to do anything
else
okay but I wasn't doing either so I
could have checked it's all with the
status of the fluids in the line in
place that was the number of things
could have been done differently to
perhaps avoid that situation
okay so one of the things I noticed in
that clip is that you could even tell
from the the body language of some of
the people being debriefed that they
were really unhappy and really defensive
and in general debriefing professionals
practicing healthcare professionals or
people even outside of healthcare who
might be experts in their field and have
experienced it a difficult situation or
one in which they made mistakes can be
really challenging people or can often
be defensive and those in those
situations when they're talking about
their performance and they're examining
their performance and even in this type
of situation where you might have video
of what they've done to show them back
so how do you approach those types of
situations well I think the reason
you're concerned about defensive this is
because defensive niskanen care learning
and the debriefing is all about learning
again learning strengths their
weaknesses how to replicate the good
things and avoid the bad things in the
future but it's also important to
remember what we talked about very early
on which was that a technical
performance debriefing is not a critical
instance just everything when I've seen
debriefings take place in other
high-risk industries the debriefings
really are not about making people feel
better
they're about making people be better
one thing to perform at a higher level
and so in an instance like that where
the team did not perform at least in
that phase of the patient care the team
did not perform an optimal level it
doesn't surprise me that they're unhappy
in fact I would expect that they would
be unhappy me I would be much more
concerned if they were happy with poor
performance that tells me that we've got
some actually significant issues in
either the seriousness with which
they're taking their participation in
that particular scenario or they just
don't understand in general how
important it is to be able to uncover
the root causes of the weaknesses that
become manifest one of the things we did
see in that clip is that going back to
some of our prior discussion the tune
did not stay at a very superficial level
okay yes the line did not go in in the
timely manner what we were able to do
the course that debriefing is actually
drill down to the underlined
causes and they were actually a number
of those that were elicited from the
people being debriefed so that's really
what you want to be able to get out of a
debriefing personally I think that if
you maintain a professional business
like matter-of-fact approach we need a
briefing thinking you're not really
excited and happy when the team performs
well you're not really sort of down and
depressed when the team's not performing
well and they're not reading you're
either we're not here using your words
or using your nonverbal communication to
assess their performance but rather
they're thinking through it critically
and then you allow you lead them through
a discussion that allows them to uncover
the underlying root causes and come up
with strategies to overcome those I
think that's where we get to the point
where actually we're going to have teams
that are again performing enough or
executing in a flawless manner doesn't
mean that they're perfect what it means
that when things don't go well they're
able to enable contingency plans and
enact those and policy execute those and
in this clip getting back to this
particular strategy you really avoided
in a specific it seemed very intentional
using the second person pronouns like
you or you guys or even addressing any
of the people in that debriefing by name
can you tell us how that strategy helps
to minimize defensiveness during a
debriefing sure I think when you avoid
the use of the second person pronoun you
that people being debriefed can be much
more objective about their performance
either what they're talking about
themselves they're talking about their
colleagues because you're not putting
them on the spot you're talking about
the physician in that particular event
for example rather than doctor your
modern Nicole and I've seen that
repeatedly and that's actually something
we've brought in from we've learned from
watching military debriefings it's
especially important when performance is
suboptimal how sometimes groups
themselves will use second person
pronouns first pronounce that's fine if
they're comfortable with that but as the
debrief er I tried to avoid that as much
as possible for example I would never
ask an individual in debriefing why did
you do
that really puts them on the spot if
they're not defensive already they're
going to become defensive instead I
would ask the team you know if it's if
if it's about the physician for example
I'd say what did the physician leading
that resuscitation just do and once we
do that and I'm referring to the the
physician in the third person rather
than by name actually makes it much
easier for that physician to talk about
his or her personal actions and whether
they were good or bad for the patient's
it also enables the people other people
being aggrieved to may not usually be in
a position where they're offering
critique to a position or to someone who
is more senior than they are and they
can talk about that physician in the
third person and it makes it easier for
them to offer their own observations
about that individuals performance so
the key is to try to encourage
discussion and courage self-reflection
of Boyd offensiveness because that tends
to get those things but then follow it
up with a series of questions where you
actually begin to drill down to the root
causes so as we've said several times
down the course this webinar the overall
goal is to be able to train these teams
so they can be brief themselves whether
the debrief in simulated events of real
events because ultimately that's what's
going to allow all of us collectively to
enhance our performance so we've talked
a lot about these strategies at the
context of taking care of patients or
even in the context of running
simulations can you comment a little bit
about how you see these types of
strategies and the things that we've
that we do talk about in our online
course being translated even outside of
healthcare sure I think the ability to
objectively self reflect and critique
one's own performance as well as to
objectively and in a non punitive way
talk about college performance is what
allows individuals and teams to overall
perform at a high level I've certainly
seen that in industries outside of
healthcare where either the lives of
other individuals or the lives of the
DPP's themselves are at stake
but I've even seen it in things like
Orion activities such as athletics where
the best athletes tend to be the one
- instead of falling apart or not
recognizing what their own weaknesses
are they're able to objectively assess
those weaknesses and then develop
strategies perhaps in concert with a
coach but develop strategies to overcome
those weaknesses those are the athletes
who can handle failure this failure
always comes to an athlete at some point
I know the ones who are able to go
beyond that and actually excel it look
all right I think with that we'll turn
it back over to - Jackie okay so our
first question is how can these
techniques be applied to scenarios
outside of emergency care for example
chronic inpatient care or even outside
of healthcare I've been in terms of
outside of healthcare I think one of the
best examples I can give actually
involved the region you people I'm the
faculty athletic fellow is sort of the
liaison between the women's indoor
volleyball team here at Stanford in the
faculty and the coaching staff uses
these strategies extremely well you
think of a coach is someone who's always
telling somebody what to do well what I
have seen coach Hamm leave you and his
staff do seemingly well is rather than
always be telling the players what they
should be doing or what they shouldn't
be doing in the huddle before the game
before the match during the match after
the match you'll ask them for their
assessment of their own performance and
what if anything they need to do
differently and these are 18 to 22 year
old young women who are very good at
doing this they just won a national
championship last year in fact so when I
see that kind of ability to self-reflect
analyze and come up with strategies to
perform at a higher level in an age
group like that I think that certainly
that's something that all of us
throughout our lives should be able to
do other high-risk industries do this
quite well affect - they do it much
better than we do in health care quite
honestly do they've been doing it for a
long time nASA has been doing this for
50 or 60 years so in any sort of
environment where the individual and
team performance is important the
ability of the individuals to
self-reflect and the ability of the team
to
reflect to put those self reflections
together to come up with an assessment
of team performance and again look at
what did we do well how can we replicate
those things in the future
and what do we not do very well what
weaknesses became manifest and what
strategies can we collectively come up
with so that we can avoid those things
in the future it really applies across
the board our next question is the
presenters indicated that working from a
recording is far preferable to going
from memory um if they don't record the
actual in the moment resuscitations to
review a at a later date do you have any
suggestions yeah that's a common
challenge that we hear about from people
who are running deep briefings and I
think you know as as we tried to show in
these debriefings it is ideal to have
that objective record to reference to so
that everybody can see both the you know
the entire group of people being
debriefed as well as the debriefer can
really see that performance and share
that understanding before really
discussing that performance but
oftentimes that may not be available for
whatever reason whether it's time or
technology capabilities and so I think
just at least having some type of an
objective record of what happened is the
goal of what you might want to start
with so even if it's not recorded
perhaps it's written you could take you
know in an in an emergency situation
oftentimes people are recording on the
code sheet the events that happen or if
it's not an emergent situation if it's
another healthcare situation again even
outside of healthcare just a record of
what the series of events were and use
that as the shared understanding of the
team of really what actually happened
and then the goal of the debriefing is
to dig down into why those events happen
as they did and what the team might have
been able to do differently or again if
it was a good performance what the team
really did well in that situation and to
try to replicate that I think it's
really important for folks to understand
that if there is no objective record of
the individual and team performance and
if you are trying to reflect on your own
performance as you were involved in that
particular event one especially if it's
if you're trying to perform under
intense time pressure your ability to
remember things
while you are you have perhaps a life at
stake or some other serious issue and
you're doing things actively it's often
very difficult your memory may be
impaired in terms of remembering exactly
what you did and when you did it how you
did it another thing that can happen is
you can if you are part of that event
you can lose objectivity and so you may
be either hyper critical or excessively
critical of something that you did or
your colleagues did or you may not be
critical enough and you may think that
you did a much better job than you
actually deal so we encourage people
especially if you are if we're if it's
possible to get video it's really
important to do that and use that
because when your debriefing it really
resolves a lot of questions about who
did what when we said what when how did
they do that it gives everybody a very
objective very concrete basis on which
to offer critique thank you we've had a
few questions about the timing of
debriefing so do you have any guidelines
and suggestions for a longer-term
retrospective debrief so outside of an
immediate setting two weeks to a month
or more and also is there an extension
of time that is considered appropriate
for a debriefing so if we're if we're
debriefing real-life events in general
you'd like to debrief those as close to
the event as possible now you do have to
sort some things out I talked about the
critical incident stress debriefing if
it's a particularly traumatic event like
for us in our field it could be the
death of a patient there are some folks
who are ready to debrief that right away
because their whole focus is on what can
we do differently to perhaps the boy
that outcome in the future and there are
other folks who from an emotional
standpoint are not ready to do that at
that time and so they may need a
critical incident stress debriefing but
what they actually can't participate
effectively in a debriefing but in
general I think that's that's a smaller
number of people so ideally what
memories are fresh great and get
everyone together debrief on that then
sometimes it's not possible to spend
much time doing that and so
when it isn't possible try to cover
perhaps the most important 1 or 2 points
and again not just very superficially
but try to deal down a bit on those and
the underlying their causes keep ask
people to create a list of other things
that occurred and then schedule an event
where you actually can bring people
together in the future and to go over
things in more detail but again
objective records are very helpful and
the ability to at least if you are going
to delay a debriefing to at least cover
one or two very important aspects of
that I think become critical in
maintaining people's interest and
helping them to you know hopefully if
their weaknesses avoid those because the
same thing could happen the next hour
the next day and if there are particular
strengths that become manifest you want
to be able to help them replicate those
in the immediate future also and then
along the same lines ideally how often
should you debrief after every event
after each new patient how long do I
think in a perfect world where
debriefing you know all the time but I
think because debriefing does take
people away from care it can be
challenging so the clearly the times
then we debrief the most often at least
in healthcare is after a mistake is made
or after a critical event in which a
patient patient status may have changed
acutely but really I would see
debriefing and even the strategies that
we use in debriefing aren't limited to
only those discussions that we title as
deeper things I think a lot of these
strategies can apply to just having
conversations with one another about
trying to uncover how we as a team could
continue to perform well or improve our
performance so for example something
like avoiding qualitative statements and
and trying to minimize defense in this
sometimes when I'm talking to my
colleagues even in very short
discussions about something that I did
or something that we did as a team I
employ those strategies with the goal of
really just trying to learn how to do
better but I think as a starting point
to that specific question specifically I
think you know after an acute event when
a patient status change changes is
really the
the clear starting point but then
learning how to disseminate these
strategies and discussions beyond that
is really our goal and another very
important point is especially for those
of you who are listening in are in
healthcare when you debrief a real-life
healthcare event you want to first have
some sort of policy a procedure in place
as to how to do that and I would
recommend that you talk to the risk
managers at your hospital or your clinic
or your school to go to know how to go
about that and that's not to say that we
want to practice defensive medicine and
cover up our weaknesses fighting means
if we determine that a weakness has
become manifested as a result of
inpatient harm and of course we're going
to talk to that patient we going to talk
to that patient's family about the
significance of that but what we want to
be able to do during a debriefing is we
want people to be able to speak freely
and if they feel that they are perhaps
placing themselves at legal risk for
their institution at legal risk they may
not speak freely and we may never
uncover the root cause of a particular
issue and so it's really to protect the
confidentiality of that agreeable get as
much information accurate information as
possible out into that discussion come
up with what the root causes are for
that event and then develop solutions
around those and then of course once
that's determined if we need to inform
the patient patients family that perhaps
yes we were an error then we need to go
ahead and do that so again talk to your
legal team it's not about practicing
defensive medicine it's actually about
getting the best information out and
then doing the right thing for the
patient
our next question here is in a debrief
setting how would you approach a person
who routinely cannot admit to or to see
that they've made a mistake and how
would you deep breathe colleagues who
refused formal or critical stress
debriefing in a less formal but more
helpful way for them I think those are
two separate questions yeah
so the first one is regard is regarding
just common challenges people who can't
see their own weaknesses or perhaps
refused to see their own weaknesses or
acknowledge them or clearly don't want
to talk about them and kind of just
lumping them all in that defensive
category I think that situation is
really a place where having an objective
record can be very very
valuable and that's why especially in
training circumstances when when the
environment allows or you know if
there's an ability to set up video
that's video is your best friend as the
debrief or in that situation because now
you have a record where you don't have
to get in a situation where the
debriefers were counting what happened
and perhaps that defensive person is
arguing with what actually happened or
what they said or did you can really
just refer to the video let everybody in
the debriefing see that and then just
talk about it in a very objective manner
you know what happened a series of
events what were the circumstances that
led to those different series of events
but then also being careful I think to
avoid perhaps directing all the
questions specifically to that person
even though you as a debriefer may think
that that person had the primary
responsibility for that series of events
but asking the group as a whole to
analyze the team's performance in that
situation and then using strategies like
we covered here where you're avoiding
the second person you're really inviting
everybody to discuss their perceptions
and their understanding of how the team
performed in that particular situation
that's a common concern that people
won't want to talk about their errors
and they'll be really defensive
again we've used video for a long time
I've been debriefing for over two
decades now and my experience with that
is actually that's a fairly rare
occurrence because the video that you
really can't argue it that it's there
and the vast majority of the time even
when people perform poorly they're more
than willing to talk about it because
it's there everybody sees it and they
want to find a way to avoid that in the
future so I haven't seen that to be a
common problem at all even though it
gets talked about quite a bit within the
healthcare debriefing community and I'm
sorry there was a second part to the
question also and yes so how would you
deep breath colleagues from who reviews
formal critical stress debriefing and a
less formal but still helpful way yeah I
think that those kinds of things some
sometimes on a rare occasion that may
actually occur during a debriefing
itself it just becomes manifest as
somebody's having a really difficult
time and really can't participate and so
our strategies are to actually
send the rest of your out for a quick
break and then talk to that person
one-on-one asking if there's somebody
that they can call right you can call to
help them out ask them if they can
continue
you can't force anyone to go see someone
even though you think they need help
what you can do is you can be
compassionate and your approach
recognize when they might need help and
offer that to them thank you
all right well unfortunately we're
getting close to the hour so we'll have
to wrap up the Q&A session thank you
very much dr. halleck and dr. Yamata for
sharing your knowledge with our
participants today and for those of you
who have indicated an interest in the
program our team will be reaching out
with more information and you can always
visit us at SCPD dot stanford.edu
forward slash debriefing as a final
reminder the recording of this webinar
will be emailed to you within a week and
thank you all for joining us today have
a great rest of your week